bonjour professeur fisher merci beaucoup
pour y d'accepter cette cette interview
avoir demandé peut-être même avant de
commencer à ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter certainement
donc je m'appelle alain fischer je suis
médecin pédiatre immunologiste j'ai fait
ma carrière l'essentiel de ma carrière à
paris à l'hôpital necker enfants malades
tant que médecin domaine des maladies
mais logique de l'enfant top chercheurs
j'ai dirigé un institut de recherche
s'appelle institut des maladies
génétiques
j'étais professeur au collège de france
jusque il ya quelques mois est donc
actuellement je suis président du
conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale qui conseille le gouvernement
sur comme son nom l'indiqué la stratégie
la vaccination entre le go in qu'est ce
que vous pourrez faire le point sur la
situation du colis de 19 en france grâce
aux mesures de confinement qui ont été
prises ces dernières semaines la
circulation du virus est en diminution
mais encore à un niveau relativement
élevé encore beaucoup de malades en
réanimation
encore trop de personnes qui décèdent
chaque jour entre 200 et 300 c est
encore ce qui signifie qu'il y à
beaucoup d'efforts encore avoir pour
contrôler ces d'épidémie je pense qu'on
va revenir sur quels sont les efforts à
faire est ce que vous pouvez faire le
point sur la campagne de vaccination
entre le vietnam et les façons de
contrôler l'épidémie
enfin les façons c'est la coordination
de deux types de mesures la vaccination
en parler tout de suite et donc toutes
les mesures de barrières physiques
individuels et collectifs et l'ensemble
étant nécessaire sur la campagne de
vaccination
le point de départ à rappeler c'est que
de façon assez remarquable en petite
année ont été mis au point plusieurs
types de vaccin contre ce virus des
vaccins qui se remarque ablement
efficace et donc il est vraiment il faut
noter le fait que ceci a pu être réalisé
un intervalle de temps très court de
l'année c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins de
temps que la mise au point des verrues
des vaccins développés au cours des 50
dernières années
et c'est vraiment tout à fait
remarquable sur le plan scientifique sur
le point d un pc industriel qu'on soit
arrivé à ce résultat et en plus avec des
vaccins
ceux qui se sont développées sur des
technologies plutôt nouvelle avec tous
les efforts toute la rigueur nécessaire
le fait que ces vaccins s'est développée
rapidement ne signifie pas qu'ils
étaient développés légèrement ils ont
été développés rigoureusement ce moment
toutes les étapes classiques dans
s'assurer de du fait que le produit est
d'une qualité pharmaceutique que le il a
été testé convenablement avant de
l'évaluer chez l'homme qu'il a été
évaluée chez l'homme de façon adéquate
pour apprécier la sécurité et
l'efficacité de toutes ces étapes ont
été franchies et en même temps des
quantités assez importantes encore
insuffisante mais assez important de ces
vaccins ont été produits donc en france
la campagne vaccinale a commencé tout à
fait fin décembre donc cela fait
maintenant un petit peu plus de quatre
mois que cette campagne rouler les
progressive accélération depuis ce
moment là et aujourd'hui un peu plus de
16 millions de personnes ont reçu une
dose de vaccin est encore un peu plus de
7 millions reçus de dos avait
vaccination complète puisqu'on estime
qu'il faille d'administrer deux doses de
vaccin pour obtenir la meilleure
efficacité
donc c'est une étape importante beaucoup
des personnes fragiles ont été vaccinées
l'objectif premier était d'abord de
protéger les plus fragiles ceux qui
avaient le plus que le risque de mourir
ou d'être hospitalisé au moins tous les
cas d'avoir des formes sévères
il était logique de commencer par ces
personnes là c'est à dire les personnes
âgées les personnes malades
donc ce processus a bien avancé il n'est
pas terminé mais il est quand même très
très bien annoncée par exemple on a
vacciné très très grand nombre de
personnes résident les autres traitent
me paie les ehpad et ce qui a permis de
réduire de façon considérable le nombre
de morts
personnes résidents de l'ehpad à cause
du corps est évidemment un résultat
attendu mais très important on est là
mais c'est pas fini puisque l'objectif
c'est de vacciner un maximum de la
population adulte
probablement il faudra arriver à maxime
et 80 85 % au moins de tous les adultes
les adultes ça commence à 18 ans jusqu'à
tous les âges pour obtenir les
meilleures chances d'obtenir le contrôle
de l'épidémie
donc si vous faites le calcul cela ça
représente environ la vaccination 45 50
personnes de doses 90 100 millions de
doses aujourd'hui on a fait à peu près
un quart du chemin voilà mais ça va en
s'accélérant donc il faudra pas non qui
sont les prochaines étapes de cette
campagne vis-à-vis des plus jeunes comme
je le disais à l'instant on est bientôt
en fin du parcours concernant la
vaccination des personnes vulnérables
donc l'idée quand on voit partir de la
mi juin dans l'axé nations soient
ouvertes à tous c'est à dire les
personnes qu'ils sont qui n'ont pas de
maladie et qui sont plus jeunes jusqu'à
18 même peut-être 16 ans tous les cas
les plus jeunes sont deux beaucoup de
jeunes se disent mais pourquoi j'ai
besoin de vacciner parce que ça puisse
comme je viens de le dire cette maladie
touche surtout les personnes âgées et
moi j'ai pas besoin je ne sais pas dans
mon risque faire une affection
ça se voit affection sans même le savoir
ce qu'ils voient c'est possible sauf que
malheureusement les choses sont pas si
simples
néamoins de raison pour que tout le
monde se vaccine la première c'est que
même pour les personnes les plus jeunes
de temps en temps le chorégraphe c'est
rare mais ça arrive et en particulier
peut survenir ce qu'on appelle des
copies de long c'est à dire que le fait
qu'au-delà de l'infection aiguë qui peut
être tout à fait banal comme une con
soit embêté pendant des semaines voire
des mois en étant très fatigués et
incapables de travailler
ce sont des choses qu'on voit aussi chez
les sujets jeunes donc éviter cela et
puis deuxièmement c'est l'objectif
auquel nous aspirons tous mais
probablement les jeunes encore plus que
les gens mon âge c'est à dire de
retrouver une vie sociale normale
de pouvoir voir sortir avec les copains
et les copines aller au cachet aller au
concert aller au restaurant aller se
balader en gros enfin bref aller
travailler en groupe
aller à l'université normalement
travailler dans son lieu de travail des
conditions socialement adéquat d'en
discuter avec les gens tout ça si pour y
arriver
c'est l'objectif si les gens se vaccine
correctement que les jeunes se vaccine
c'est un objectif qu'on peut avoir pour
la rentrée prochaine et donc c'est
vraiment après tout on peut considérer
que c'est un génie même si c'est une
vision collective des choses c'est un
bénéfice individuel chacun puisque je ne
vais attendre 25 ans 30 ans enfin peu
importe de se dire me vaccine ans le jeu
je participe du contrôle de la
circulation du virus et donc je pourrai
retrouver une vie sociale normale comme
je l'avais dans une commune c'est
vraiment la vision qu'il faut avoir
et logiquement semble que ce arguments
cet argument est à peu près
incontournable pour penser qu' il est
raisonnable de se faire vacciner à
partir de la mi-juin donc pour les
personnes en bonne santé qui longtemps
sachant que les personnes je rappelle
quand même le lui même âge mais qui sont
malades peuvent déjà ceux qui pensent
que la vaccination est nécessaire pour
en arriver à retrouver une vie normale
et à quoi est-ce qu'on pourra s'attendre
si le succès facile vaccination de masse
présenté par a réussi le virus il est
très contagieux c'est à dépenser en
moyenne que le virus tels que celui qui
circule aujourd'hui donc c'est modifier
un tout petit peu au virus qui était
présent au début de la maladie
est plus contagieux est ce à dire qu'en
moyenne si on prenait aucune mesure
aucune preuve aucune précaution qu'une
protection etc
à chaque fois qu'une personne serait
affectée et la main moyennant
affecterait quatre autres parfois
beaucoup plus parfois moins en moyenne
qu'à 30
et donc on peut il ya quelques
mathématiques simples qui m'ont qui
permet de déterminer que si on veut
casser cette chaîne de transmission et
donc le fait qu'ils étaient nouvelle
personne malade donc c'est des personnes
malades et des personnes gravement
malades des génies qui ont dû casser
cette chaîne de transmission
eh bien il faut que 75% de toute la
population basque à l'âge inclut les
enfants ou bien 80 85 % des adultes
soient vaccinés dans ce cas là on
arrivera à faire en sorte que le une
personne infectée ou contamine moins
d'une statistiquement pains et à partir
de ce moment là forcément l'épidémie
progressivement diminue finira par être
très très fort et donc pour réduire
cette contagiosité il ya deux types de
mesures
l'une évidemment c'est d'éviter dû
limiter les contacts partena se laver
les mains éviter d'être présents
ensemble en grand nombre c'est un
certain nombre de mesures que chacun
connaît pas moins de monde donc
télétravail etc
et puis là et ça ça réduit la
transmission le comprends mais ça repart
à chaque fois qu'on arrête ces mesures
et la seconde mesure c'est la
vaccination c'est la réponse à votre
question on avec le principe de la
vaccination se de générer une réponse
immunitaire
curieuse de telle manière que si on est
en contact avec le virus
une enveloppe sa réplication n'est pas
malade et sans doute tous les cas pour
certains vaccins ces cas on évite de
transmettre le virus
donc on réduit aussi la compta gest
c'est incontournable
s'ils ne se vaccinent pas on masse tous
les âges
on est 18 ans 30 ans 50 ans 70 ans 90
ans n'y arrivera pas et si on veut
retrouver vie normale et sur les
terrasses des cafés ou à l'intérieur des
cafés à les chanter danser
le seul moyen qu'il ya pas mal de jeunes
qui sont pas mal procurer pop art leurs
problèmes en particulier est ce que vous
pouvez parler un petit peu de risque qui
pourrait y avoir six présentes on
continue avec les restrictions de
circulation notamment en termes de
précarité des jeunes ou de santé mentale
c'est sûr que le tout ce qui a dû être
mis en place faute de mieux
qui sont des contraintes sur la vie
sociale et les jeunes que ça peut être
pour certains la vie scolaire et
étudiantes dont qui se fait très très
grande partie ou encore les études en
télétravail ce qui est certainement pas
la meilleure manière d'apprendre c'est
une forme d'isolement d'isolement qui
est d'autant plus fort que les étudiants
sont isolés à distance de la famille
souvent ceux qui sont les conditions
sociales les moins favorisées
c'est une perturbation de ses études et
cela crée évidemment de laudun anxiété
ont certes un peu on peut entraîner des
exemples des dépressions pour des jeunes
qui ne sont pas qu'ils ne sont plus en
études qui travaille ça peut-être le
même soit d'ailleurs parce que
malheureusement ils sont au chômage
parce qu'ils travaillaient les avez un
boulot des professions qui aujourd'hui
sont sinistrées gens qui traînent des
cafés ou les restaurants certains types
de magasins soit il travaille mais dans
des conditions difficiles parce qu'un
nouveau ils sont isolés ils sont
essentiellement télétravail quand ils
peuvent travailler et évidemment ce
n'est pas la meilleure situation
psychologique
on va travailler en groupe d'une part de
ne plus pouvoir voir ses amis autrement
par des conférences ou des rendez-vous
visio ce qui est bien mais comme très
très insuffisant donc on sait qu'à une
souffrance créée par cette situation et
donc c'est un argument supplémentaire à
la vaccination c'est plutôt les gens se
seront vaccinés plus tôt on sortira de
poura évident pour réduire puis
complètement faire un projet de faire
disparaître ces nécessités de
contraintes et et faire en sorte que la
vie sociale de tout un chacun
j'avais déjà paraît un peu limité de
groot mais à quel point ce que les
vaccins actuels du cours réduisent
qu'est ce qu'on sait sur leur capacité à
réduire les risques de contamination
très précis aujourd'hui en ce moment
nous disposons de deux types de vaccins
les vaccins dits arn le principe c'est
qui séquence génétique des ânes qui
permettent une fois injecté produit chez
la personne vaccinée de fabriquer une
des protéines du virus et une sur 29 et
cette protéine a entraîné une réponse
immunitaire donc et sont des vaccins
très efficaces et qui très probablement
agi sur la transmission réduisent
beaucoup le risque de transmission non
seulement il prévient la maladie pour 90
%
presque toutes les formes graves de la
maladie à tous les âges notamment chez
les personnes âgées mais en plus donc
font en sorte que les personnes
vaccinées ne transmettent pas mieux donc
ça c'est un peu un résultat évidemment
qui est très positif
voilà la seconde famille de vaccins
disposant sous les vaccins fondée sur
des vecteurs adénovirus c'est à dire
qu'on incorpore un petit peu du matériel
génétique du virus nouveau le même le
constituant une des 29 protéines dans
des virus qu'on a modifié pour les
rendre inoffensifs n'appelle les
adénovirus et donc on injecte c'est
adénovirus inoffensif et ça permet la
synthèse à nouveau la protéine qui
induit donc ces vaccins live c'est le
vaccin sera zeneca par exemple janssen
récemment disponible en france
j'en ai vaccin tout aussi efficace mais
pas quand on ne sait pas pour l'instant
on n'a pas d'informations de savoir
s'ils réduisent la transmission mais
moins l'information
elle nous a pas rappelés vaccin est ce
que
c'est déjà un peu décrit le
fonctionnement est ce qu'on rentre un
peu plus sur les tailles de comment
commencer à fabriquer il fonctionne
la haine est un constituant biologique
majeur de nos cellules savait que notre
génétique et mattel génétique de tous
les êtres vivants pratiquement et est
composée d' adn et l'adn il est copié
sous forme d'une molécule la rn qui est
un messager qui ce qui est transférée du
noyau cytoplasme des cellules et à
partir de du code génétique de la rn une
cellule peut fabriquer des protéines
c'est un constituant essentiel de la vie
et pour les vire pour ce qui est des
virus certainement de virus ont un
matériau génétique qui n'est pas
composée des reines l'adn excusez moi
mais d'air c'est le cas du coronavirus
arscott 2 mai de plein d'autres virus
virus de la grippe
donc ça fait longtemps que des
chercheurs quand je dis longtemps ça
fait 20 ans 30 ans que des chercheurs
réfléchissent test des méthodes pour
utiliser la havane pour vacciner est à
dire les premières tentatives ont
commencé il ya quelques années sur le
plan de l'application chez loeb avant
c'était une recherche au laboratoire
dans le domaine du cancer avec l'idée de
vacciner contre les cellules cancéreuses
d'augmenter la réponse immunitaire des
malades a donc ce soir c'est pas une
tête c'est pas une technologie tout à
fait nouvelle tous les cas c'est une
technologie sur laquelle il ya eu des
efforts de recherche considérable depuis
un très grand nombre et donc il se
trouve que ces recherches en termes de
mélioration progressive ont abouti au
moment où s'est posé la question de
développer des vaccins contre le sar
scop 2 vous êtes est immédiatement très
rapidement et très efficacement
appliquée aux ars co2 en utilisant donc
les rênes d'une protéine principal du
virus qui s'appelle à spahic cette
protéine qui permet au virus fixées sur
des cellules de désinfecter et c'est une
protéine à l'égard de laquelle la
réponse immunitaire les anticorps et
l'immunité cellulaire sont très
importantes
donc voilà c'est ces vaccins étaient
préparés en quelques semaines cette
remarquable une fois que le virus était
connu que la séquence génétique du virus
était connu et en quelques semaines dès
le printemps 2020 ensuite ils ont été
testés
j'ai chez différents types d'animaux
sourit jusqu'aux singe pour s'assurer
que il protégeait ses animaux contre la
maladie qui a été montré qu'ils étaient
sûrs et ensuite ont commencé à l'été
dernier des essais cliniques
on a testé chez l'homme donc important
évidemment ces vaccins d'abord pour voir
la dose ou comment ils étaient tolérés
et puis démontrer l'efficacité pour ce
faire on fait des études cliniques où on
tire au sort
la moitié des individus reçoivent le
vaccin et l'autre moitié ressources
qu'on appelle la place et vont donc faux
vaccins et ensuite on compare dans les
mois qui suivent là on regarde la
protection est ce que les gens
développent la maladie ou pas la maladie
ou d anticorps par des anticorps et en
faisant cela on a montré ce qu'on
appelle et c'est cette phase iii jargon
de la recherche médicale clinique où on
a montré que ces vaccins de type arn
protégeait à 95% sa maladie ça veut dire
que là où les sujets placebo par exemple
20 cas n'a plus que 1 g sujets vaccinés
et ensuite une fois ses résultats connus
le vaccin produit le vaccin autorisé par
les autorités réglementaires
il a donc commencé à être utilisé vers
le mois de décembre est par exemple en
israël ce type de vaccin était utilisée
massivement il a pu être montré des mois
de janvier février que le effectivement
le résultat qui avaient été obtenus dans
les techniques étaient confirmées avec
une très très bonne efficacité et
duisans l'infection les formes graves
les décès et la transmission et ça a été
aussi confirmée ailleurs unis si bien
que dans les pays où la vaccination est
très avancé on a observé une réduction
importante du nombre de cas d
hospitalisation en particulier voilà le
bilan actuel de l'utilisation de ces
vaccins avec adresse qui sont sécurisées
écoutez donc aujourd'hui pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur
il y avoir dans le monde 500 ou 600
millions personnes au moins peut-être
même un peu plus ça avance tous les
joueurs qui ont reçu ces lacs 5 c'est
considérable donc s'il va y avoir des
accidents on le saurait en pratique est
très très peu de choses ces vaccins sont
très bien tolérées de façon
exceptionnelle il ya des personnes qui
ont une réaction un peu forte d'à peine
une anaphylaxie ce sont des gens c'est
très très rare c'est moins d'une
personne sur cent mille ce sont des
personnes qui ont dans d'autres
circonstances ont déjà eu des
intolérances à des produits qu'ils
auraient été administrés et qui se
connaissent un risque qui n'est pas
utile injecter un produit qui les
protège
en dehors de ça il ya eu très peu de
choses ce sont des vaccins qui sont
vraiment sûrs efficaces et encore une
fois avec maintenant à un recul est
encore que le quelques mois mais quand
il ya les actions avec les vaccins c'est
précoce n'est pas distant et testé sur
des centaines de vidéos personne
absolument consignes à forcalquier au
pari de tous les vaccins l'âge par les
interroger sur les vaccins et rennes
j'ai répondu les vaccins et je peux voir
réponse est souhaitée pour les vaccins à
des nombreuses dont l'efficacité est
comparable à celle des vaccins à et
rennes s'étaient montrés notamment dans
le bretagne
les britanniques ont utilisé très tôt
dès le mois de janvier
le vaccin dit astrazeneca adénovirus ils
ont montré que à tous les âges de la vie
l'efficacité est la même donc en termes
de tolérance pour ce type de vaccin on
observe un peu plus qu'avec lot de
vaccins des réactions de fièvre de maux
de tête frissons 48 heures qui suivent
la vaccination uniquement chez les
sujets jeunes d'ailleurs pas chez des
sujets plus âgés mais c'est quelque
chose de très agréable mais qui est
transitoire et qui passent de façon
absolument exceptionnelle c'est l'ordre
de fréquences par exemple en france et
28 cas pour près de 4 millions de
personnes vaccinées ont observé une
complication qui sont la formation de
caillots de sang des thromboses c'était
observé évidemment à l'étranger aussi
nous attendent et 28 pour 4 millions
donc ce sont des risques qui sont de
l'ordre d'avoir un accident de voiture
si sortant du bureau la première la
voiture
vous faites 20 km d'avoir un accident de
voiture grave c'est ultra et son s'est
aperçu que ce risque était un peu plus
important toujours très rare il peut
plus important chez les sujets plutôt
plus jeunes comme par ailleurs en plus
ses moments de la vie où le risque de
coheed est moins important et bonjour
donc la conséquence c'est que par
prudence pour être vraiment sûr éviter
que les vaccins posent problème ce type
de vaccin est utilisé actuellement que
chez les personnes âgées de plus de 55
ans ou là le profil de sécurité très bon
alors qu'il est un petit peu moins bon
pour les sujets jeunes et on préfère
qu'ils utilisent les vaccins fait sur
une fois ce sont des évènements
extrêmement rare mais comme en indiquant
cela aussi je fais remarquer que on a
les systèmes de surveillance de la
vaccination ont permis de détecter des
événements très rares ce qui montre à
quel point il ya une vigilance très très
attentif qui est exercée sur ses vaccins
on s'assurer que les choses il n'y a pas
de préoccupation autour du fait que ces
vaccins soient genre de sur aix en tout
cas seront sont créés par des
entreprises est produite par des
entreprises
quel point ce qu'on peut faire confiance
à ces entreprises vous expliquer comment
on fabrique des vaccins sans entreprise
possible et comment vous vivez dans la
vie sans acheter le moindre produit
quelconque entreprise
on a vous tous mais plus jamais de
médicaments vous n'allez plus dans un
supermarché ou ne fait plus rien la vie
et mentionnait qu un système d
entreprise ça veut pas dire que les
entreprises sont toutes parfaites fond
des choses idéal mais c'est la réalité
de la vie donc pour que le système
fonctionne il est sain de contrôle de
régulation c'est ça qui est important
une régulation c'est le fait que avant
qu'un vaccin puisse être administrés à
quiconque
il est caractéristique de ce vaccin
terme sont produits la qualité la façon
dont les produits sont efficacité
sécurité du chemin de tout à l'heure
tout ça est examiné par un très grand
nombre d'experts qui n'ont rien à voir
avec l'industrie des scientifiques et
qui travaille pour des agences de
régulation pour ce qui nous concerne
l'agencé européenne du médicament qui
fait ce travail qui a fait ce travail
pour les vaccins nous a parlé il ya la
même chose aux états unis à des degrés
divers dans tous les pays du monde
je peux vous assurer que avant que le
feu vert soit donné
il ya des études très très attentif des
dossiers qui sont donnés par des
dizaines et des dizaines d'experts sur
des dossiers qui pèse ce format papier
émis et page si vous le voyez où les
gens qui l'écoutent là le voyez serait
probablement effrayé et la met juste
pour dire et c'est sale élément
important c'est que le système est
contrôlé ce contrôle doit nous donner
confiance
de fait c'est ce qu'on observe puisque
ces vaccins depuis qu'ils sont utilisés
par des centaines des millions de
personnes dans le monde
en france le 17 millions personnes et
assure une première dose ça fait quand
même beaucoup de monde ça se passe bien
ça se passe bien parce que tout a été
drôle et pour s'assurer qu'il ya beau
lisez notre crise
excusez moi mais ça n'a aucun sens si on
répète que si on considère que par
définition une entreprise produit
quelque chose auquel on ne peut pas
avoir confiance
on peut juste enfermé chez soi ne plus
rien faire en permanence nous vivons
dans un monde soit on travaille dans une
entreprise qui n'est pas en te soit on
achète des produits notre domaine de la
santé les vaccins les médicaments
d'autres vous juste que le système soit
sous réglementation soit régulée c'est
ça qui compte et c'est ainsi on observe
aussi la défiance envers les autorités
cinq casques des éléments pour justifier
une confiance envers les autorités
sanitaires en france il ya eu des années
d'études inapproprié moi c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qui ont été mis en place
progressivement en france notamment des
systèmes de contrôle de réglementation
qui sont plus strictes de ceux qui
prévalaient le passé et qui sont des
garanties ses systèmes de contrôle étant
de plus indépendants des autorités
sanitaires sont pas les mêmes personnes
qui s'assure de la qualité des produits
vaccinaux que ceux qui décident en
france de dire qu'on peut les utiliser
ou des décisions que prend le
gouvernement ce sont des gens qu'on m'a
demandé que chaque citoyen exerce sa
vigilance à l'égard des autorités
c'est normal il n'y a pas un de défiance
a priori surtout je le répète que le
système ici on veut bien me regarder de
plus près et éminemment contrôlée par
parfois de vaccinations altruistes et ce
qui me plaît expliqué oui on revient à
la notion de l'immunité collective c'est
à dire que quand on se vaccine et qu'on
agit sur la transmission du virus d'un a
parlé tout à l'heure il vient on évite
d'infecter des autres et parmi les
autres il peut y avoir des personnes
plus fragiles que soit parce qu'elles
sont plus âgées parce qu'elles sont
malades chez lesquels et personnes chez
lesquelles la vaccination fonctionne
moins bien on ça qu'elle fonctionne ont
toutes les catégories mais parfois moins
bien donc ça veut dire que ces personnes
quand même un risque résiduel matière
sont vaccinés des dettes ma natte et
même éventuellement d'être gravement
donc si je me vaccine et que je vais
voir mes grands parents et qui sont
malades fragiles et que je je peux les
voir sans leur transmettre le virus je
les protège aussi même si eux mêmes sont
pas complètement intrinsèquement protège
c'est ça l'unité collective c'est que si
suffisamment de personnes en bonne santé
avec un bon système immunitaire parce
qu'elles sont en bonne santé qui sont
les mieux protégés contre le virus les
mieux à même de ne pas transmettre le
nose plus ces personnes là ce sont en
vacciner plus elles protégeront les plus
fragiles qui sont moins bien protégés
par la vaccination
donc il ya un caractère altruiste la
vaccination ne se protègent pas même
d'une bas on protège les autres ses
proches c'est en barrant typiquement ses
parents malades de saige ou d'autres
personnes dont son environnement qui les
personnes qui pourraient se dire dont la
sim et parents sont actionnés pourquoi
est ce que j'aime avec son message pour
ses parcelles et bien si si si on dit ça
m'a pas tout à fait compris comment les
choses se passent pas ce que ça veut
dire qu'un grand nombre de personnes
resteront nous protéger nous on continue
à faire circuler à produire du virus de
temps en temps de tomber malade
même si elle a vu que c'était rare ça
peut arriver quand même les
inconvénients direct pour ces personnes
et puis elles vont continuer quand même
à contaminer des personnes plus fragiles
qui sont pas protégés à 100% par le
vaccin
mais je répète ce que je viens de dire
les personnes les plus âgées c'est kamel
moins évident que que pour les plus
jeunes donc on va perpétuer l'épidémie
ça va continuer si ça continue
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça
signifie on va continuer de confier on
va être obligé de suivre ses
coordinateurs on peut pas aller voir les
copains au café et ainsi de suite
on continue nos systèmes qui prévaut
maintenant à des degrés divers depuis
une bonne année avec toutes les
conséquences que cela a sur plan
psychologique social c'est juste
catastrophique et pas possible c'est
simple
donc il faut axer les cheveux aussi au
delà de se vacciner cas pas faire les
spectateurs de cette vidéo pour
augmenter la couverture vaccinale est un
rituel est bien parler à ses copains ses
copines jean sa famille les collègues de
travail et que sais-je les collègues
d'études alors disant réexpliquant
j'espère une notion convaincu
l'importance de la vaccination répéter
ce que je viens de dire sur le fait que
cet élément absolument indispensable qui
va nous permettre progressivement dans
les mois qui viennent espère d'ici la
rentrée de revenir à une vie normale
mais aussi en n'oubliant pas que pour
l'instant il faut aussi encore respecté
les gestes barrière il faut lier les
deux mesures c'est pas l'une sans
l'autre ce sont les deux et mieux on
appliquera les le sait mieux respectés
gestes barrière d'une part et plus on se
vaccine d'autre part plus vite on
récupère et vie normale et plus vite
comme chacun pourra retourner au cinéma
au concert au café
allez voir les copains dehors que celle
enfin bref une vie normale de personnes
qui vous attend dès la question
qu'est-ce que vous avez des conseils à
donner à ceux qui doivent parler à des
gens qui ont peur de se faire vacciner
ou qu'ils ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner
il a expliqué qu' il n'y a pas de raison
d'avoir peur parce que les vaccins sont
sûrs que s'il n'était pas sûr il serait
pas le ministre est ce qu'on appelle
l'analyse comparaison du bénéfice et du
risque dans la vie tous les jours on
prend des décisions sont pas forcément
prêts sont conscientes mais qui on parle
des bénéfices j'ai traversé la rue je
peux me faire écraser par une voiture
c'est un risque extrêmement faible on
n'y pense pas et c'est très bien aussi
vivement l oxydation c'est la même chose
niva une pense pas au reste parce que ça
se passe pas assez rigoureuses
exceptionnel et par contre on sait que
c'est efficace
donc il faut rassurer aussi les
personnes qui
super merci beaucoup merci à vous